How's it going everyone? Today
we're going on a bit of an adventure and we're going to look at two different integrals
from I guess two ends of the mathematical spectrum and at two vastly different price points,
we're going to compare them and see which one gives the better experience.
Now I'm not alone in doing this. I've enlisted the help of someone with very fine taste in mathematics,
and that's Jen's from the channel flammable maths.
Now Jen's is a seasoned integral taster
so he is going to walk us through today's delicacy, an integral which requires complex analysis.
To start with though I'm going to walk us through today's budget item and it's an essential tool in the toolbox of any budding
mathematician.
Today, I'm going to be integrating everybody's friend e to the x. Now
i'm working at what is essentially a poor man's version of a blackboard today. It's a sticker on a wall with lots of bubbles
but you get what you pay for I guess. Now e to the x is a function that was almost designed to be integrated or
to be more particular, designed to be differentiated. e to the x is a creation of mathematicians,
we made e to the x because we wanted a function, call it y
where the slope of y at every point was equal to the function itself.
Now this is satisfied if y does equal e to the x.
We can have a look at how y or e to the x would be
constructed and let's first think about where it would start.
So if we wanted to start at x equals zero
and this is e to the 0 which is 1, so y at that point is going to be equal to 1.
All right. So, let's write down and construct our y of x.
We know it starts at 1 and we know that the derivative of it
dy/dx
is going to always be equal to the function itself. So that's going to have to start with a 1 as well.
Now this is also the derivative of this and
we know that for a 1 to be in a derivative, it means there must have been at least one
function of X in the function itself.
So if we have 1 plus x that will correctly give us the derivative 1,
but in doing that these are no longer equal anymore,
so we've got to make them equal. Let's add that x down here as well and that
gives us the same problem. To have an x in the derivative of a function
there must have been at least an x squared power in the function itself.
In fact, it would have had to be x squared over 2 to give us this derivative,
but you know, we need to keep these equal to each other. So we're going to have to add that term here as well.
We seem to be going around in circles a little bit.
Then this is going to keep going on like this,
you might recognize the pattern to actually be x to the n over n factorial,
where for example here n was 2, this is 2 factorial it's just 2 and we've got the squared power at the top and
so
this here, and this keeps going, this is going to be
our series representation of the function e to the x. That's what it's equal to.
Now you might be familiar with e the number as being like 2.7...
That pops out of here - if we were to set e to the x,
with x equal to 1. If x is equal to 1 this is just e
and if that's going to be always a 1 this would be a 1 here. This would be 1 squared over 2. That'll be 1/2
and so that's already
2.5 there and each of these smaller terms are gonna you know, get to be very small numbers
we're going to keep adding on successively smaller amounts until it, you know gets to around the value of
2.7 blah-blah-blah-blah. All right, and that's the familiar face of e that you might have seen before.
This is a way of writing it out that shows you in a way how e came to be it was designed so that
the derivative of the function was always going to be the function itself.
Using the property of e to the x that we just went through we can write down its integral as e to the x
plus our boi C. Now
if you've done almost any integration at all, you'll remember or you'll recognize what C is,
he's our friend that we just have to remember not to leave behind.
He's the constant of integration and he's there because you know,
he doesn't depend on x,
so the derivative of the C would have been zero and so it's very possible that there could have been some constant here
where when differentiated it disappears so we've got to leave that there just in case.
But this is our integral pretty basic, pretty intuitive and very widely useful.
So when tasting integrals,
we've got to consider multiple things such as the value, the complexity, the beauty of the integral and you know,
it's usefulness, and I'd say this one scores pretty highly. I think it's you know
got a big bang for your buck,
you're getting a lot of value out of this. You can use this integral in a lot of places,
it'll make math pretty simple for you, and it's pretty elegant as well.
So I'm looking forward to seeing what our next integral looks like and how it can rival this one here
but let's hear from Jen's on that one
[train crash sounds]
Good morning fellow shrimps.
Thanks to Toby for inviting me to her little show right here, but Toby are you serious?
That's not what I signed up for.
Take a look at that. I can't integrate this.
I don't feel worthy.
I physically can't integrate this function right here.
What the hell do you think you are giving me here? I'm out!
[Hold music plays]
So
My manager just talked to me and he told me if I don't integrate this function, then I'm gonna be fired
So I guess I have no chance right here
we are going to give this thing right here shot using complex analysis today because that's just really elegant and
You see that's the function and we are going to call this thing I for integral
You can also call it J for Jen's. I really don't care or T for Toby
And at first I would like to define a complex function a complex valued function
We are going to call it f of z and we are going to define it as follows
That's natural log of z squared over z squared plus 1 and if you take a look at the denominator right here
What is plus 1 that is nothing but
Negative i squared where i is the imaginary
Constant and you see that's just a difference of two squares and we can factor it. So that's quite easy
So we end up with natural log of z over z plus i times z minus i and
This denominator right here gives rise to two poles two singular poles at that
So where are our poles at? They are part of Western Europe. I know that but also
We can just take a look at here
so poles are just points where our
Denominator would go to zero and our function would explode to infinity you could say
So that also means we have two poles at one and two at the points i and negative i so plus and minus i and
Now we can take a look at the contour because if you want to use the residue theorem complex analysis
we would like to take a look at a contour integral of this complex layered function f of z integrated with respect to z
Okay, that's cool. But what does our contour look like? Well for this I would like to take a look at the complex
plane and
Just it at the upper half. So this makes things easier
So why not take a look at a semicircle in the upper half of the complex plane? But here's the thing
We have a singularity you could say if we plug in
Zero into here in this natural log of z this function would explode to negative infinity. We don't want it
So we have to get around the singularity. That's a branch point
So why not construct a little semicircle around the origin right here with a little radius of Epsilon? I don't care and
Our outer semi circle has a radius of R. So this goes from R and
negative R right here to negative epsilon and epsilon because epsilon is just the radius and
This thing right here is just a contour
C, that's what we are going to call it and also our outer semi circle
It's nothing but gamma we are going to call it this and our inner semi circles nothing, but I don't know capital lambda
So that means our contour integral right here consists of four parts. We have this gamma integral and then also we have this
Lambda integral and also we have two other integrals one on the real axis
So here we are going to integrate with respect to z but those are just running on the real axis
So we have another integral running from negative R to negative epsilon
f of x dx so just changing those complex-valued
zs right here to just real valued axis
And also another integral from epsilon to f of x
dx
But also like I said before we would like to use the residue theorem
So those 4 parts added together are equal to 2 times pi times
i times the sum of the residues in this case
but we only have to consider one residue because our contour just has the residue of i
In it, so this singular power i
so z one right here the residue at the point z one and we're going to calculate it now
You might ask yourself now
What the hell is the residue at the point z being equal to i?
Well, we bois here at BuzzFeed are going to do it that way
We do nothing but apply the limit when z approaches i
to z minus i times f of z but what exactly is f of z?
It's nothing but the natural log of z squared over z plus i
Times z minus i and you see it is it's going to cancel out quite nicely
That's why we factored it in the first place and well now we can just apply the limit without any
complications so we have the natural log of i
Complex number that's weird squared over two times i because i plus i is just two times i
You might ask yourself now. What exactly is the natural log of I well
We can just take a look at the complex plane for that
so this right here is a complex plane with this being the real axis and this being the
Imaginary axis and where exactly is our point i it's just up here and
if you take a look at the definition of a complex function
z it's nothing but r times e to the I Phi
where r is the length of our vector right here in R2 you can say and Phi is just
Angle enclosed by this vector and real axis. So that means if we just go up here to i
What's our angle? Well, this is pi over two, but now you could say hmm
what if we go around this way once again and land here, this is just five times pi over two and again and again with
Some K times pi over two K of some
Integer number. Well, we're just going to take a look at the principle branch right here being pi over two
We're just going to do that. We are not making it more complicated than it already is and what exactly is our r?
Well, it's just length of the vector but i is on our unit circle
so that means r is nothing but one so it also means that i it's nothing but e to the i times
Pi over 2. And if we apply the natural log to both sides
Natural log of e to the something is just the something itself. So i times pi over two and here we go
We are done and we can plug this in so we end up with i
times pi over two
But the whole thing squared over two times i and well i squared is nothing but negative one times pi squared
over four times two times i so this is a times i and now we can just plug the value of this residue into our
Contour integral and then we are basically done
So all I really did was just plug everything
Into what we have gathered before and you might notice on this expression right here our is don't cancel so that makes it real valued
that's cool and our two and one over eight is going to cancel out somehow to
one over four so we end up with
This additive chunk right here to be just negative pi to the third power over four
Okay, that is cool. And now I would like to take a look at only this integral right here
So we are going to write it out
Okay, we are going to end up with an integral from negative R to negative epsilon of natural log of x squared
Over x square plus one
integrated with respect to x and
Well what we can do now we can just introduce a substitution
So let x be equal to negative x or negative u you can call it whatever you want. It's just a dummy variable
So what we want to do
We want to let x be equal to negative x that also means that our dx is going to be transformed to
Negative dx and we can plug all of this chunk in
So what happens to our upper and lower bound well they just change signs to R and epsilon in this case?
So we have natural log of negative x natural log of a negative number. That's weird
Once again, we are going to talk about this in a minute
Over well negative x squared is just x squared. It doesn't change plus 1 negative dx and
Now we can distribute this negative
Sign into here to change the order of integration into the integral from epsilon to R of
the natural log of negative x squared
over x squared plus one dx and
For this natural log of a negative number, I would once again just like to take a look into the complex plane
Let's put it here
So just like before we have talked about
the vectors before so z being equal to r times e to the i Phi and
On the real axis our negative 1 is right here. So that means we are going to go this way and
We are enclosing an angle of Pi in this case
taking the principal branch once again and also its lying on the unit circle this negative 1 so our r is going to be 1
that also means that natural log of
Negative x it's nothing but well we can use the natural log property because this is just negative 1 times x
so turning it into the natural log of negative 1 plus the natural log of x and
Well natural log of negative 1 in this case
So a negative 1 it's nothing but e to the i times pi taking natural log on both sides
It's just i times pi it's as easy as it is so we end up with i
times pi plus natural log of x
And we can plug this new information into here. So
we end up with let's put this in a box to integrate from epsilon to R of
The natural log of x plus i times pi
whole thing squared over x squared plus 1
integrated with respect to x and you
see we can just use the binomial formula up here in the numerator to end up with an final integral from epsilon to R of
natural log of x whole thing squared plus our natural log of x times
i times pi and now i times pi squared. This is just negative pi squared
negative pi squared over
x squared plus 1
dx and I'm going to write everything out and I see you back in a second
So as you can see, I just wrote everything out nicely and do not wonder about this expression. That was just
Integral we had derived a second ago, but broken up into three different integrals and since
Those are just additive we can just break them up. And now I would like you guys to consider something and also the girls
Around here on this channel
If we would just let epsilon goes to 0 on the limit and R go to infinity in the limit
well
There would just be our original integral that we wanted to evaluate
Same thing here so we can add those two together in the middle. But what exactly what happened for
Example to those gamma integral and this lambda integral
Well, we are here at buzzfeed, you know, and we have a lot of money
So the ad revenue is falling from the sky all day long, but what we don't have is a lot of time
That's why we went to our local complex analysis dealer
You know this guy does selling you lemmas and theorems and stuff like this and we bought a little DSC called?
Jordan's lemma and we can use it on those two right here
all it really does is to let lambda integral go to 0 in the limit when epsilon approaches 0 and if R
Approaches infinity gamma is also going to 0 so this makes things real
Really easy and we are going to take the limit on both sides now and see what we get
so
We end up with the limit as epsilon goes to 0 and R goes to infinity of our contour integral
I'm going to write it like this
This is just on on this side right here where this is just the limit of a constant
It doesn't affect our constants or negative
pi to the third power over 4
being equal to
This and that is going to vanish we can add those two together and I want you guys to notice if we and
Girls to notice I'm so sorry this needs to be politically, correct. No, I I have no idea but
If we let epsilon approach 0 and R infinity that's just our original integral I
so we have 2 times I plus i times pi and
This one doesn't really concern us
We are just going to call it J now. It doesn't really matter
So this is just J like Jens the mathematical name guy,  that is probably me and also this integral negative
Pi squared times the integral from 0 to infinity of dx
Over x squared plus 1 and you see this right here is really easy to evaluate
This is just the inverse tangent  this integral right here
Of x in the limits from zero to infinity and well in inverse tangent of zero is just zero and inverse tangent when x approaches
Infinity is just pi over two. So this is just pi to the third power over two. So what do we have?
We have negative pi to the third power over four be equal to two times I
Plus i times pi times J
Negative pi to the third power over two and what we can do we can add this expression on both sides
So adding PI to the third power over two also here PI to the third power over two
this is going to cancel out and this thing right here is exactly going to evaluate to
The positive term right here so you can advance this fraction by 2 over 2 and you immediately see where this comes from
So this is just PI to the third power over
4 equals to 2 times I plus i times pi times J
And since 2 isn't equal to 0 you can prove this by using piano axioms or something
Or you can just trust a BuzzFeed guide right here on this we can divide both sides by 2. So
This by 2. This is going to cancel out this by 2 and if we divide this by 2
this is just PI to the third power over 8 and
You see the real part of this complex number?
So real part imaginary part is just going to be the value of our integral that we wanted to evaluate
So that also means the real part of this contour integral
f of z dz contour integral is nothing but pi to the 3rd power over 8
so if we just compare coefficients you could say and this is nothing but our
We are done my boys and girls and everything else in between
the value of our nice little contour integral right here is
PI to the third power over eight and this thing is worth a million bucks
Probably because it's just so damn cool complex analysis. It's awesome
And if you did enjoy this video, please like and subscribe to the shrimp and me
I'm flammable maths if you didn't know already and up until the next video have a flammable and
Tibees day, cya